mi hanno invitato qui a parlare però
visto che ci siamo mi sembrava gentile
onorare le tavole di questo palcoscenico
ma
grazie grazie
innanzitutto volevo tranquillizzare la
mia compagna vanna che è qui tra voi
perché sono tre giorni che mi sento
girare per casa
parlando da solo e volevo
tranquillizzare nel senso che è tutto ok
siccome parlare mi viene un po più
complicato che suonare ho dovuto fare un
po di di prove in casa e quindi è tutto
a posto
cosa succede a un ragazzo di 14 anni che
nasce cresce ad ascoli piceno
quando si accorge che una delle sue
passioni ha preso il sopravvento e
quindi non si può far altro che seguire
cercare di seguire a qualunque costo
questa strada e spesso ci si può fermare
alle prime difficoltà e quindi si rimane
in un territorio circoscritto ci si fa
il bagno nel laghetto sotto casa e
questo per un milione di ragioni
semplicemente perché è più semplice e si
evitano critiche conflitti invece quello
che ci voleva fare questo ragazzo di 14
anni
cioè io era cercare di trasformare la
musica cioè la propria aspirazione in
qualcosa di più di più concreto qualcosa
di più grande e per farlo mi rendevo
conto che siccome si trattava di un di
una zona diciamo non molto convenzionale
dovevo fare questo attraversando dei
confini cioè varcando proprio dei dei
confini e invece che fare il bagno del
laghetto tuffarsi nell'oceano con la
precarietà di un camaleonte che fa surf
da lì il titolo di questo è un
intervento che come un camaleonte verso
l'infinito e oltre il titolo l'ho preso
componendo c'è prendendo delle citazioni
di due film che mi hanno particolarmente
colpito il primo è il camaleonte di
zelig di woody allen nel personaggio che
si adatta a qualsiasi cosa
mentre verso l'infinito e oltre è la la
voce registrata del robot di cioè di
buzz lightyear sono nel film toy story
che ama dire questo slogan super
positivo pur rimanendo sempre nella
stessa stanza
quindi la necessità qual era di
realizzare questo progetto e soprattutto
adesso vorrei rispondere alla domanda
che forse in molti di voi si stanno
facendo in questo momento cioè come può
venire in mente una persona che nasce ad
ascoli piceno di diventare un bassista
super mega sensazionale come me la cosa
più più divertente e come trarre
profitto facendo qualcosa che ti piace
così tanto
cioè come trovare qualcuno che è
disposto a pagare per sentirti e vederti
suonare questo super mega un cul e lei
come dicono i minions è abbastanza
complesso comunque partiamo in sintesi
dall'inizio fin da piccolissimo per me
la musica ha sempre rappresentato un
linguaggio spontaneo cioè come partiva
una canzone mi metteva ballare è quello
il primo sintomo
quindi se qualcuno figli e succede
questa cosa è tutto a posto non è
è una cosa preoccupante quindi ho
iniziato a suonare il violino perché mio
padre suonava il violino quindi non
c'era un motivo di particolare passione
però erano lì lolini quindi ho iniziato
e da subito mi rendevo conto che il
violino non mi emozionava nel senso che
non avevo questo desiderio pazzesco di
suonarlo tutti i giorni però studiando
lo capivo che la prima cosa che mi
emozionava era ascoltare una melodia e
riprodurla in automatico quindi sentivo
una sigla alla televisione
prendevo il violino e rari facevo adesso
la faccia mente nuovi in basso vediamo
se qualcuno di voi la riconosce
l'avete riconosciuta questa è la
generazione del 70 se la ricorda e
quindi mi divertivo a fare questa cosa
qua
e invece quando dovevo eseguire gli
studi di violino davanti all'insegnante
forse per renderli meno noiosi li
cambiavo e questo scatena va lei era
dell'insegnante ma proprio tipo no no
non devi farle così però a me mi
divertiva però che dovevo fare andavo
avanti
cercavo di flirtare anche con altri
strumenti come il pianoforte che quando
su di violino lo fai complementare però
non mi piaceva neanche quello
chitarristi ce ne erano troppi veramente
troppi come in romagna negli anni
ottanta tutti facevano i dj quindi era
diciamo un settore un po inflazionato e
poi questa cosa sicuramente vi farà
ridere infatti l'ho messa apposta non mi
sono mai piaciuti i capelli lunghi e lo
sapevo
grazie ho poi provato con con la
batteria ma era troppo faticosa da
trasportare
era un po troppo nel retro file poi alla
fine il fato ha deciso per me cioè il
primo gruppo di cui poi avrei fatto
parte aveva il bassista che era
costretto a partire per il servizio
militare e non solo era partito ma aveva
lasciato nella sala prove
il suo basso e il suo amplificatore
quindi come io amo dire e come dicono i
piloti di aerei
ho beccato lo slot sono arrivato e in
una settimana ho tirato giù tutto il
repertorio che loro stavano provando da
mesi e lì lo studio del violino è
servito molto perché mi ha dato
disciplina rigore e ha sviluppato il mio
orecchio tantissimo tutti e due non solo
li capisco che quel gruppo sarebbe
sempre rimasto una cover band e quindi
avevo bisogno d'altro dovevo varcare dei
confini e fare un'altra mutazione qui
ritorna il camaleonte surfista mi piace
che questa figura del camaleonte
surfista no con gli occhi un po così che
sta sopra e perone e rimanevo sempre ad
ascoli e quindi cercavo di gravitare in
tutte le micro tendenze della città
quindi c'erano i jazzisti quindi
arrivavo ambiente lo so non è così
loro adorano fare un sacco di smorfie
però stanno fermi inchiodate no e quindi
frequentavo i funk ha quelli che
sentivano il funky quindi andavo da loro
mette quel basso un po più giù e suonavo
con loro poi andavo da quelli che
facevano levi metal e quindi cambiava
l'impostazione molto aggressivo e il
basso andava sempre più giù sempre molto
arrabbiati erano sempre molto arrabbiati
non se ne capiva alla ragione cioè
smettevano risuonare ciao come stai
addirittura come le voci molto così e
poi è arrivato il gruppo punk e li più
giù di così non si poteva andare
era non era tanto una nota ma una sola
frequenza di rumore però avevo preso in
considerazione anche quella
poi è arrivato il confine vero l'oceano
ci si muove verso milano questa è stata
la mia faccia appena uscito dal treno
alla stazione di milano la prima volta
perché io non è che avessi poi così
viaggiato in famiglia quindi arriva
milano e li dico ok
questo è il big data l'universo però
come si faceva mi serviva il passaporto
ideologico io lo chiamo così cioè non è
che il passaporto per andare al di là di
un paese era proprio ideologico dovevo
capire la chiave di accesso così mi sono
attaccato come un francobollo a questa
persona che si chiama robert gligorov
era molto inserito conosceva tutto del
mondo dello spettacolo
oggi magari
mi sarei definito uno stalker ero
proprio fisso da lui quindi il mio primo
impiego musicale o forse strumentale al
fatto di poi essere accreditato come
bassista era fare il tuttofare per lui
quindi davo da mangiare fregatti guidavo
la sua macchina scaricava i suoi bagagli
scaricava la spesa di sua moglie però
nel frattempo lui mi presentava un sacco
di persone però non ero ancora proprio
pronto cioè non c'era stata la quella
mutazione finale che mi aveva fatto
capire ok se è pronto ma non ero così
pronto che robert mi disse vieni con me
a parigi ti porto a a vedere sting che
registra un disco io dico fantastico
sting ok vado guidò fino a parigi perché
il dealer a quello dei guidare la
macchina fino a parigi arriva a parigi
incontro sting robert mi presenta lui e
saturnino ed è un bassista giovane sting
mi guarda e gentile prende il suo basso
dello porge mi dice questo è il mio
primo basso io lo guardo
prendo il basso non so cosa fare e metto
a posto il basso sul cavalletto
guardando lui e che succede il basso
cade e questo sia un momento veramente
un highlight
il basso cade e succede che tutti quelli
presenti nella regia si girano come per
dire ma che cazzo coseno perché guardano
me ho detto vedi sono riuscito ad
attrarre l'attenzione su di me ma non è
questo il verso giusto non ero ancora
pronto
poi invece succede che tutte le cose che
hai fatto fino a quel momento sembrano
magicamente lavorare all'unisono per
assistenti in quello che stai per fare
mi trovo in uno studio di registrazione
a milano dove poco tempo dopo avrebbe
registrato un album molto importante per
la sua carriera a lorenzo jovanotti
l'album è una tribù che balla correva
l'anno 1991
l'artista per cui avevo registrato lì si
chiama gatto panceri e devono autore
molto conosciuto il proprietario dello
studio mi ascolta mi vede mi conosce e
quando lorenzo chiede sto cercando dei
giovani musicisti per mettere su una
band
il proprietario dello studio massimo
lepore che non finirò mai di ringraziare
disse il bassista ce l'ho io mi chiamo
io arrivai subito in studio e
incontrando lorenzo capì che il basso
caduto di sting il basso suonato così è
tutto quello che era successo il violino
tutto erano serviti e stavano vibrando
veramente all'unesco poi più o meno
quello che è successo dopo
molti di voi se lo se lo ricordano e lo
conoscono
però la sintesi di tutte queste
mutazioni e tutte queste esperienze è
arrivata a 20 anni fa quando mi trovavo
in studio e finalmente mi sono reso
conto dopo di aver trovato la mia voce
cioè era venuta fuori dallo strumento
che che imbracciava una melodia che è
riuscita a far vibrare tipo
l'allineamento dei pianeti nell'universo
e quella mia di basso fa così
all
tornando un po indietro
ricordate quando vi ho detto che mi
piaceva tirare giù e per rifare le
melodie che arrivavano dalla televisione
questo che avete ascoltato adesso è la
baseline che su cui si è costruito
l'ombelico del mondo che è un pezzo che
io considero la mia pensione
quindi diciamo che siamo riusciti nel
primo progetto nella prima fase
progettuale però è rimasta quell'aspetto
camaleontico che è riuscito a far
mimetizzare all'interno di questo pezzo
una sigla che io tutte le sere quando mi
trovavo a cena con i miei sentivo e che
mi ha trapanato al cervello che era la
sigla delle previsioni del tempo di
bernacca infatti lo stacco dell'ombelico
del mondo che ritmicamente fa così io
dovevo sottolinearlo con il mio
strumento perché arrivava in un certo
punto e ci ho messo questo
e non se ne è accorto nessuno
concludo dicendo che l'adattabilità del
camaleonte è per quanto mi riguarda la
forza della vita quindi andate come un
camaleonte verso l'infinito e oltre
grazie a tutti